Here's how to actually scale an
education business. You feel like you're
losing customers. You're not sure how to
expand. And so education businesses,
one, are they sellable? Two, are they
valuable? And then three, where do they
go wrong? I'm going to cover it all
right
now. Back streets back. All right. Or is
it let's go? I don't know. I actually
don't know the words to the song. Don't
know the words to any song, believe it
or not, except for one uh that I did for
poetry class in seventh grade. Anyways,
that's not why you're here. Here's the
issue. Many people have education
businesses, books, courses, coaching,
all of that stuff. And they want to make
sellable businesses. They also want
their customers to never leave. And so
they have these problems, which is that
customers are leaving and their business
isn't sellable. And they think there's
something wrong with their business. And
the answer is maybe. So let's dive into
this. Number one, what makes Harvard
Harvard? Well, number one is that
Harvard has standards. So they have many
people apply and only a few get in. If
you accept everybody who has a credit
card, that's not a very high standard.
And so if you want to create a brand
around education, you can't let
everybody in. Thing number one. Thing
number two, Harvard makes no promises.
They don't say, "Hey, you're going to
make this much money and you're gonna
make this many days." They've
completely, you know, gone away from
that. And instead, it's just it costs
this much money to get in and you might
not get a result. Now, here's the here's
the craziest part. Number three, not
everyone passes. Not only does not
everyone get in and everyone pays with
no promise, not everyone passes. And so
if you just look at those three
criteria, there's more, but if you just
look at those three criteria, you'd be
like, "Oh, that's why they're different
from 99% of other education businesses
in general. They also do education."
Now, what else is different about their
thing? Well, it's in person versus
remote, which is probably again another
big differentiation for the vast
majority of these businesses. On top of
that, the network of the quality of the
people is probably the most valuable
thing that they give on top of the
brand. They just curate an experience
for very smart people and they slap
their brand on top of them.
fundamentally that's actually what they
sell. What's the next issue that comes
up for most people of like why is my
business not a Harvard? They will then
get into well my customers leave. So do
Harvards. They leave after four years.
Now they also have an extended time
horizon in terms of the promise of when
someone might get to the end of this
thing. Yours is 6 weeks. Theirs might be
six years. What is continuity in the
form of education? Well, every quarter
you have new courses and you have a
curriculum. And so a lot of people who
are in the education space are like,"I
want to teach this one thing and I want
people to pay me for it forever." And
the reason for that is because people in
the education space mistake a payment
plan for continuity. So if you have sell
something that cost $12,000 and you give
them access to it for a year and people
pay $1,000 a month, you don't have
churn. People have graduated. You have a
payment plan, not continuity. If you're
trying to solve for continuity or solve
for sellability, let's let's let's bring
let's go into those. Why not? We're
partying, right? A business that has
enterprise value has reliability of
future cash flow. Meaning there's a high
likelihood that this business will
continue to make money in the future.
And so typically like a Harvard has a
brand and so because of that brand,
they're not worried about demand, right?
They can demonstrate the fact that they
have a certain number of people who are
applying every year and a certain number
of slots available. And so because of
that supply demand discrepancy, because
of the brand that they built, they are
able to likely if it were a private
enterprise, uh well it is private, but
it's not a nonprofit. It's not a
for-profit institution. It's a nonprofit
technically. Let's not get into that.
point is is that for your business to
have value, you're going to have to
build a brand around it that guarantees
demand in the future because, and this
is the big one, because education does
not lead to continuity except under one
circumstance. So, let me explain. So, if
you teach someone to do a thing, they
usually learn the thing if you're good
and then they graduate from the thing
and they should do that. But a lot of
people are like, "Man, I want to have
recurring revenue." But the thing is is
that you have to break up the
deliverable that you have into two
different columns. All right? So, this
is a good exercise for you to think
through. Column A is what's the stuff
that someone uses one time gets the
value and then after they get the value
it's no longer valuable. So if I teach
you how to sell and then you know how to
sell I don't need to teach you again you
already have the value. If I teach you
how to generate leads for yourself as
soon as you learn the skill the skill
now continues to provide value but I no
longer provide value to you in teaching
it. Right. Right. So there are education
components which are typically onetime
value. People aren't on a like for a
Harvard for example they teach you you
know communication 101. Okay. after that
semester, you don't take communication
101 again. And it would be weird if they
tried to charge you again for
communication 101 because you're like,
"Well, I already I already know it." But
we do this and as a we as a
entrepreneurs who who who do education
stuff try and do this stuff all the
time. Now you're like, "Wait a second
then. How did Gym Launch sell for a lot
of money if there was enterprise value?"
Ah, because most people mistakenly think
Gym Launch was an education business.
And that's because the people who profit
from education businesses try to sell
you on that. as the owner of gym launch.
I can tell you the vast majority of the
enterprise value in that business was
not from
education because there's other things.
So I said column A is onetime value.
Column B is consumables. Things that
continue to provide value again and
again and again. If you look at your
service, which I like to think about
from that perspective, what are the
other things that you have in the
business that someone must use again and
again and again?
Examples for gym launch. One of the
primary things that we do there is that
we go and test ads in representative
markets. We spend our own money to get
ads that we know work. And then once we
have that ad, we then sell it at a
margin basically to everyone else. And
it's 100% gross margins for us after
we've incurred the initial cost of one
filming the ads, you know, uh, editing
the ads and then displaying the ads,
actually running them, putting the money
behind it to see which ones are the
winners. But once we scoop up the four
or five winners, we can just hand them
to a thousand or 10,000 locations and
they are valuable to each of those
locations because within those local
markets, they are new ads. But what do
you need next month? More new ads. And
so it is a consumable that has 100%
gross margins that can be sold again and
again and again. What else do you think
someone could have that is consumable?
There's a there's a great school
community, for example, where they do 3D
printing. So the guy teaches 3D
printing. How do you do it? How do you
set it up? Whatever. Onetime value. And
then after that, every month, he scour
the internet for new products that are
hot and trending right now so that you
could set up with your 3D printing
business. And so people stay every month
because they can get this list, the hot
list, and then they grab the things off
that list and they stay in there. And
for him, he just has to do the one-time
work of creating the list and then he
can sell it over and over and over
again. But people stay because they
don't want to lose it. I'll give you a
different business. There's a real
estate business and they have super low
churn. And one of the reasons they have
low churn is because every month he has
bird dogs. So basically people who go
out and scout for properties and he puts
a list out of properties that meet his
criteria for his way of doing
wholesaling. And so then people pay to
be in his community in order to have
access to this list of fresh properties.
So he does the onetime work and then he
basically licens that or fractionalizes
the sale of that to many people. Now
these are these are the consumable
consumables. What other ones are common?
Let's list let's think through them. So
one of them is you've got community.
Community in and of itself is actually a
consumable thing. You use it this month,
you use it next month, right? These are
things that you can do. These are
fundamentally why network effects exist.
If you can build a valuable enough
network, people don't want to leave that
network. And fundamentally, that's what
communities are on a micro level. Now,
what are other things that you might
use? You use traditional services,
right? So, if you have a marketing
agency, you might pay monthly. If you do
SEO, you might pay monthly. And so, we
have to look at our deliverables and
think what are the things that are
onetime and what are the things that are
consumable. And then, here's the key
part. We have to price them
appropriately. The reality is that
education extremely valuable. There's a
reason that Harvard can spend, you know,
charge $60,000 a year or 70 or whatever
it is now is because that that is very
valuable to educate someone gives them
they basically pay today to increase
their skill set so they can increase
their future earnings. That's what
education is about is literally
increasing someone's future earnings.
That's why people learn Or if
it's, you know, if they want to learn
how to paint, then I mean they could
obviously monetize that too. But some
people just want to learn how to paint
or they want to know how to do music,
they want to learn how to sing, whatever
the skill is, right? But they pay today
because they know that they're basically
paying a discount over the long haul as
long as they learn the skill. So in this
context, how do we get customers to
stick? One is with the pricing, we want
to price the onetime value as high as we
possibly can relative to what people are
willing to pay. On the consumable part,
we price it where people are also
willing to pay if the other piece didn't
exist. So think about this. This is the
big mistake, right? This is the big
mistake is that people will price their
consumable at a payment plan of their
onetime upfront value. For example, if
something's worth $30,000, then they
say, "Cool, you can pay $2,500 a month
for 12 months and you're going to get
this onetime value and this consumable
value." But then once people have kind
of drained that onetime value, and
sometimes it takes less time than a
year, then people exit because the
consumable value is not worth the
$2,500. This is why I'm a big fan of the
or big advocate of the big head longtail
model, which is maybe the upfront thing
is worth really $10,000 and your
consumable thing might be worth a
hundred, it might be worth 200, might be
worth 500. I don't know what that is.
But if you only sold that, so this is a
good mental frame is if you only sold
this thing, what do you think would be a
price that people would not want to
leave? That's the price you have for
your continuity because that is the
price that people willing to stay at.
And typically, it's significantly lower
than a a uh a spread out version of the
upfront value of whatever the
educational skill is. And so you have to
differentiate those things. Now, beyond
that, you might be like, well, shoot, my
consumables aren't worth that much.
Fine. Then structure your pricing so
that you always have a value discrepancy
between what you charge and what they
what you what you deliver. Now the other
piece of this is okay well I want to
have enterprise value in the business
which means that I should have a
reliability of future revenue. Sure we
have a little bit of our consumables
that will stack up over time. Great. We
have our upfront which typically serves
to liquidate the acquisition cost at
least how I like to structure things for
the high high margin continuity that
goes on the back end. But what else can
we do? Well, what does Harvard do? They
sell you more courses. They sell you
more degrees. You want to have a you
want to have a bachelor's. Guess what
you have now? You want to get a masters?
Get a masters. After a masters, what do
you get? You get a PhD. Well, after a
PhD, what do you get a double PhD? You
get a super duper PhD, right? They'll
keep selling you. But the thing is is
that's the continuity. That's the latter
is just what's the higher level version.
But they also know that it's that it's a
it's a fraction of that, right? If a 100
kids go to uh get a bachelor's, it might
only be 10% or 20%, I don't know the
numbers, 20% that they get a masters.
And of the masters, maybe it's only 10%
of them to get a PhD. Also, the pricing
also reflects that. Interesting. Right
now, back to the stickiness of the
business. A piece of advice. Don't start
an education business and then say, "I'm
going to make it a SAS company." Famous
last words. Now, if you're white
labeling somebody's tool, whatever. It's
not really yours and fine. That's really
just you being an affiliate of someone
else's thing. Whatever. But if you're
like, I'm going to start something from
scratch, the likely that you succeed is
basically zero. And when I say succeed,
it's like actually have a true software
exit. I have yet to see literally yet to
see and I look at a lot of businesses
and I kind of sit in this space like I
understand pretty well. I have yet to
see a business that has successfully
done this and the likely that you were
the special snowflake is probably not a
bet that I'd be willing to make. You
might feel like a special snowflake.
Your mama might have told you you're a
special snowflake. Your father, well,
hopefully he didn't tell you a special
snowflake. He should hopefully have have
you prove it. But the point is it's
unlikely and I prefer to make bets that
where if I wait I win. And if I look
around and look at the marketplace and
no one's won using this path, it's
probably because it's a flawed path. And
it is because when you attract someone
with education, then you're trying to
keep keep them with software, it
typically doesn't work unless it's a
core function of the business and you're
fully focused on it, which you probably
are. So if you want something that is
super sellable, then you want something
that's sticky. If you want something
that's sticky, then make the business
about the sticky thing. A lot of
stickiness here, right? Now, the trade
that most people in education and even
media companies make is that instead of
having something that is inherently
valuable as an asset, they tend to just
make more money than they otherwise
would with a similar scale business in
just about any other space. And I see
that as the trade of future value or
future money for today's dollars. I'll
give you a story. So, a buddy of mine
had a business. He worked on it for
between 8 and 12 years, I can't
remember. And he took a salary of
$70,000 a year. And at the end of that
period of time, he sold the business
software company for $250 million. So
$70,000 a year for eight years, 10
years, 12 years. He lived on Dave Ramsey
style, uh, paid his house off, like
lived on that. And then boom, $250
million. He could have done an education
business and maybe made $10 million a
year for that whole time. He's skilled
enough of an entrepreneur. And so the
question is, how do you want to make
money? And I want to be clear, I don't
think there's anything wrong with
saying, I have a business that makes me
$10 million a year that I'll never be
able to sell. Well, you get to enjoy the
$10 million every single year. So, I
mean, life's only going in one
direction. It's getting shorter. So, I
mean, I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with that. There's this
kind of mantra of what I call the three
marshmallow problem. So, there's the the
typical story of the child who, you
know, gets put into a room and he gets
one marshmallow now, and if he doesn't
eat the marshmallow, he gets two
marshmallows. The problem uh with that
for those those of you who learn how to
delay to gratification is that once you
learn that skill, you then want to delay
gratification forever and then you hope
for this third marshmallow that might
never come. Think about different
versions of this experiment. If we were
to say, hey, you get one marshmallow now
and if you wait a year, you can get a
second marshmallow. Is it worth waiting
a year for a second marshmallow? Like,
is the payoff of a second marshmallow
worth it? Maybe, maybe not. Is it worth
it at 10 years? Is it worth it at at the
end of your life you get the second
marshmallow? Maybe, maybe not. And so I
think a lot of people ma uh mistake
delaying gratification with maximizing
gratification. Yes, it's true. Delaying
gratification in general tends to uh
especially at the beginning increase
your reward. But at some point there is
a diminishing return in my opinion
beyond which you should just get your
reward right also there's this uh
misconception I think that by taking the
reward unlike the experiment that it
prevents you or precludes you from
getting another marshmallow again later
which often times it doesn't. And so I
think there's a sweet spot and that's
like most things is that the magic is in
the middle is being able to balance both
extremes. And what many people will do,
strive especially, will just suffer for
extended periods of time and then
sometimes they don't even get the second
marshmallow and the first marshmallow
stale. I don't see an issue with the
fact that the business that you have
might just generate more cash flow and
not really be that sellable. That's
okay. It's a trade you make and I think
that's a it's a reasonable trade. But if
you want to get have your cake and eat
it too, then there is one specific type
of education that does have continuity.
And so that's what I I'll dive into. So
obviously all the components that I
talked about that are consumables, those
will drive continuity. But there is one
specific type of education that drives
continuity, which is continued
education. So there are professions
where you have to stay upto-date with
technology. You have to stay upto-date
with new practices. where if you can
build a business where you reertify
people on new skills or new technologies
that come out on a consistent basis,
then that membership, which is really
what the business is, that membership
business can over time continue to
compound and you can demonstrate that
people will stay with you for an entire
career. If you can demonstrate that,
then you have a business that is very
valuable and is an education and can
sell at almost a tech multiple. And
fundamentally, inherently technology
businesses aren't they don't get these
multiples because it's not like, oh, I
have a software, therefore I I get a
software exit. Like, no one gets this.
And the thing is is that people will
preach this because they want to sell
you on that idea. But that's not how an
investor sees it. The things that make a
software valuable are the things that
make a business valuable, which is that
there is revenue retention, there's high
gross margin, there's high incremental
margin, there's less operational drag at
scale. These are all the things that
make software companies at scale more
valuable. It's not that the fact that
they use code that makes them valuable.
If you sell people into a software and
they turn out, you know, every six
months, that's not valuable. It's
basically the same as a service and
you're going to be valued based on the
fact that you have customers that come
in every, you know, come in and out all
the time. And the thing that you'd have
to establish is a brand that would then
prove out the fact that you're going to
continue have demand like Harvard for
years to come. And so, if you're not
doing this, then you're basically just
building something that generates cash
flow, which to be fair, I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that. But
the big misconception is the idea that
number one, there's something wrong with
it. Number two, that I have to add
software or something to make my company
valuable, which it won't make it
valuable. It'll likely make it a
distraction and decrease the size of the
business. Number three, we're go we're
cranking. You're charging too much for
the consumption and too little for the
education. You probably need to do this.
Charge more for the upfront thing
because it is life transforming value.
And then charge less for the thing
that's ongoing because it probably is
less valuable than the other one. And if
you're like, I'm not sure if mine is
less valuable. Well, just look at your
chart. People are telling you if it's
less valuable. And if you don't have
something that is consumption based,
think about what components of whatever
it is that you sell someone must consume
on a monthly basis they use and reuse so
that you can get them to buy again and
again. So these are my qualms with
education done right. This is how I
think about it. And hopefully that that
should put to rest one uh how do I sell
my education business? Well, it's not
about an education business. It's about
keeping a business that keeps customers
for a long time and having high gross
margins. I gave you one model that does
work. The other model is having a stack
of consumables. Continued education is
also a method that works there. But
again, that's the new thing. That's the
PhD. That's the masters. It's
certification level one, two, three,
four, five, six, right? It's it's the
extra thing that you're doing. And you
have to understand that there's going to
be a trade-off or drop off at each
level. Now, if you sell only continued
educ education on the front end, then
you have people already have a
prerequisite. So then the issue there is
going to be finding the people already
have their prerequisite that matches
your continued education demands. All
businesses have problems. Now, if I
wanted to go use my marketing skills on
something because you probably if you
sell education, you have to get good in
marketing and sales. It's one of the
parts of the business. If you want to
build something like that, then let me
give you the easiest hack in the world
to build something that's really
valuable. Find stuff people already
don't stop buying. Then use your
marketing and sales skills on that,
which is fundamentally what we did with
private equity. So, what do I put in my
feature set to make it stick here? So,
number one is I would add as few things
as possible. And you likely can delete
things. This is big. This is very big.
How many education businesses do you
know that include calls, accountability,
some sort of resource library, uh
library of all past, you know, Q&A calls
or one-on-one calls? Probably a lot of
them. Have any of them solved
churn? No. If you want to have a feature
set, the way that I think about feature
sets is that I want each feature to be
on its own valuable enough to more than
justify three or four times the price.
If someone can't just say it's worth it
for this alone, then I don't want it in
the stack. And that may mean you only
have three or four things or two things
or one thing and you just do it really
well. That's fine. So that's in terms of
how I'm thinking through it. In terms of
what things should I should I add and
when we have to answer what problem are
we solving? If people are churning and
you have an education business, well
unless you're doing continued education,
that is the nature of the business and
you're probably mispriced on the back
and probably mispriced on the front end.
In terms of when to add it, it would be
when I know that this particular service
is something that people consume again
and again and again. So if you get
repeated questions month after month
after month of a problem that that needs
to get solved, this is where service
businesses start to sprout off of
education. Now, what you'll realize is
if you do the service well, the service
business itself will be more valuable
than the education business because
they're not coming for the education.
They're coming for the service. They
come for the service. They'll keep
paying for the service if it's good.
Part of the reason that sometimes
service businesses even if the service
should be sticky, they aren't sticky is
because of the nature of the customers.
So let me explain that. So if you have
customers that are inherently volatile,
then their volatility will reflect on
the volatility of your product or
service. And so if you're dealing with
VSNB, so very small business owners or
proumers, people who just, you know,
they have a job and they they kind of
upgrade. Those people are notoriously
volatile. They're going in and out all
the time. They, you know, get
passionate, get unpassionate, they get
whatever. And so it doesn't matter how
good the thing is, you're going to have
churn that's going to be there. And so
you have to make sure that you're
comparing what churn, what you expect to
churn or you want to get to. Like uh
Facebook has super high churn. If you
think about churn is people who stop
using the product. Now I say super high
relative to salesforce but way better
than every other social media platform.
And so uh you look at Shopify. Shopify I
think is considered best-in-class. They
think I think they have 55 or 60%
renewal on an annual basis. Meaning they
lose 40% of customers every year. But
the people who stick after that year
stick for the long haul. You're going to
have involuntary churn, the lower on the
um axis you go. What you want to make
sure is that after people reach a
milestone, they never leave. So that's
what you're really going for. So if you
have some period of time, let's call it
12 months, where people turn in and out
and then after 12 months, no one ever
leaves because they they reach certain
uh benchmarks or certain activation
points. If you get there, then you have
a valuable business because those people
you just have this year up front that
doesn't matter and doesn't really factor
in the value of the business. But the
valuable part of the business is you do
this functionally as a sales motion in
order to generate this reliable
recurring revenue stack and you're just
filtering through to find the diamonds.
So the question was what kind of churn
benchmarks exist so I know if I'm doing
uh you know good or bad. I I can tell
you on school because we have a lot of
metrics there. Uh 18% monthly churn is
the average school community churn. So
if you're doing 10% you're doing like
basically about half that. So that's
it's you know decent good. Uh if you're
above that you probably have some things
you can improve on. Uh if you're at 5%
so that means that you have 20 month
LTVs. If you're like how did you do that
math? All you do is you just take one
divided by your monthly churn. So one
divided 10 by 10% monthly churn means 10
months of average stay. 5% is 20 months.
One divided by point. You know if you
have 1% turn then you have uh 100,
right? 100 months. What's good? What's
bad? Well, the lower the better. Duh.
The the piece that we I would really
care about is M12. So the the 12 month
retention. How many people get to month
12? And of those people, what's my turn
on them? If my turn on them is zero,
then I'm very excited, right? If they're
also just slowly turning out as well,
then I just have this very long tail and
I have to always keep selling people,
which of course every business has to
keep selling people. The percentage is
going to matter based on the industry
and who you serve by a wide margin. If
you're serving high-end enterprise, then
it should be like you should be 80%
annual renewal or higher. If you're
serving, you know, beginners, then it's
going to be it's going to be high and
that's also a feature, not a bug. It's
just part of selling to that customer.
For me, what I care about fundamentally
is the cost and the return of a
permanent customer. So, let me let me
break this down. This is probably the
most important concept. All we care
about in any business is how many
permanent customers do we have. So let's
say that you have, you know, for every
10 people who buy your education, three
of them transfer over to your service.
And of the three that transfer your
service, one of them never leaves. Then
we just have to know, okay, it cost me
10 times my current cost to acquire a
customer to get one person who never
leaves. What's that LTV to CAC ratio? If
you're having just your LTV to CAC ratio
for for front-end business, that's
different than LTV to CAC LTV to
permanent what's my permanent CAC to a
permanent LTV, they just never leave.
And if you're like, well, I don't I
don't really have that yet. Well, yeah,
cuz that's the hard part of business.
Once you figure out the product market
fit of what's my feature stack, what
type of customer is that feature stack
better, you know, better served for? So
that 12 months from now, these people
never want to leave. Once you solve that
part, that is the hard part of business.
That is the hardest question to solve.
Once you solve that, then everything
else is basically just math of how do I
find more of those people? And if I have
to go through five to get to one, then
this is one permanent customer and then
it just becomes a cash flow question,
which is why people raise money and then
they get really aggressive. But then you
want to see like, okay, is there a way
that I can either select better on the
front end or is there a way that I can
increase activation so it becomes one
out of four instead of one out of five.
But we have to get to that one point you
have a permanent customer and then build
backwards from there. When do you upsell
other feature stacks? Well, it's going
to be based on their need. If someone
comes in and has all of these needs,
then you'd sell it nationally at that
point. If someone has one problem solved
but then creates another problem, a
simple example would be like, "Hey, I
teach people how to do, you know, DM
setting or whatever." So, you teach
people how to, you know, reach out to
people and create appointments. Okay.
Well, once they learn how to do it
themselves, what's the next thing
they're going to want? They're going to
want other people to do it for them. And
so, if you want to sell a service of
placement for those people or sell some
sort of like fractionalized service
where you have a pool of people that
works for many people or you say, "Hey,
I'll employ them myself so you don't
have to deal with the liability or risk,
but I charge 20% above and I pre-train
them and that's the ongoing rate." Fine.
Like these are all different business
models you could have there, but you
can't sell the the GM setter, I don't
think. Well, you could upfront, but
likely they would have to have the
business model and understanding first
and then you would upsell them on the
back end. So offer timing matters just
as much if not more uh than the offer
itself. Like sometimes you have the
absolute right offer and you're just
offering at the wrong time. So people
say, "Hey, I really want to start uh you
know a business that has enterprise
value." They'll say, "I want a real
business." I don't think there like
fundamentally if you exchange goods and
services for money, then you have a real
business. So you've got some you got to
deal with your own head trash on that.
If you define real business as a
business that becomes an asset that's
sellable to somebody else, fine. I
understand that. But don't let anyone
make you believe that there's something
inherently wrong about the business you
have. If you follow the law and you
exchange goods and services for money
and you make a profit, then there's in
in the eyes of Alex, there's nothing
wrong with what you do. You you you use
the skills you got to to provide for
your family. I don't think there's any
shame in that. I I would die on that
hill. Beyond that, if you're like, I
would just prefer to have a different
business or I'd rather have a business
that doesn't rely on I'd rather have a
business I could sell someday because I
have whatever goals that I have. Fine. I
have yet to see the I'm going to use my
cash flow from my education thing to
feed my uh you know software or service
business and then let that take off.
Usually what ends up happening is that
both businesses end up taking your
attention and the service business
doesn't put as much cash flow out.
Neither does a software company. And
your lifestyle has already accustomed to
the the higher income level that you've
generated from your high cash flow
business. And so, uh, you never really
want to give it up because you don't
want to take a lifestyle cut, which most
people can. And so, they end up not
being able to pursue it. If you do make
the jump, you can win. So, I want to be
clear. Sam Ovens from school had
consulting.com, sold and shut down
consulting.com, went all in on school.
Alex Becker with Hyros had Market Hero,
which is an education business, sold and
shut that down, started hyros, went all
in on Hyros, made it work, and both have
succeeded exceptionally well. Same same.
If you want to do it, do it. But no half
measures. Well, hopefully that puts uh
the nail in that coffin for those of you
who are unsure about that. I get that
question probably twice a month and
hopefully that just resolves that. And
if you like this type of business
breakdown, I actually break down real
businesses all the time.